let me see something right now life is a
fantasy and I'm gonna tell you this I as
a family I just feel like we don't need
to carry around baggage and resentment
and hatred in our hearts
I feel like this family is gonna work if
we just were clear about how we feel
about each other I don't want anyone in
here you know have you heard of the term
flower shielding yes we episode episode
is called flower show yeah a flower
shield Enrique though yeah I don't want
to see your face and see a smile but in
your heart there's anger okay and I know
for a fact there's someone in this room
right now that has something to say to
me and I don't like the fact that this
[ __ ] bastard comes into my house
you mean with resentment and anger and
he doesn't say anything he smiles as if
we were all good we're all good in the
hood now I want to say I'll just call it
out Georgetown USA has something to say
to me and he's not saying it and I'd
like to hear it before we get into this
[ __ ] podcast would you like to go to
the [ __ ] mic right now prepare this
time doorstop Louis because I also I
would before you say anything George
watch what you say and watch the tone
friend also can I just say yeah you have
to allow the man to speak good no
interruption order him station but then
about this once he says his piece yeah I
have to say my people and no one
interrupts my [ __ ] piece is that the
captain sure go ahead George
firstly let me say you're a good friend
Bobby they get that's not how you while
you know what already you lost already
you long no let me tell you a story of
back in the day okay first came to LA
yeah I was a little aspiring producer
it's long before like I'd produce videos
that had gotten billions of views on
YouTube with the top new media stars and
like Kassem G Wow
Kassem G I had no idea for God I was a
little sag
hey no interruption I know but he's not
even a part of any Union but anyway go
you know I was a little little unpaid
intern at Will Ferrell's company oh wow
just okay you know I was like go ahead I
know I met a girl there like you know
and as guys do when they meet a girl
like I found out she lived in my
neighborhood I invited her out to drinks
you know it was a Wednesday tradition
berrigan's it's no longer there anymore
what they had to dollar and fifty cent
margaritas and this was a pretty good
time to like invite girls too so she
came to this two dollar and fifty cent
margaritas yeah tonight Wednesday night
at berrigan's uh-huh and we had a great
time we were just chatting we had so
much in common
we were both aspiring producers we
bonded over French new-wave films
we both had master's degrees and
producing oh and then then my friend
showed up my good friends you know I
think they should probably like act like
good standing humans you know my friend
Steve a lawyer
my friend dick a doctor probably and
their significant others as well Dick's
wife Steve's girlfriend at the time
mm-hmm so they show up and instead of
joining us as a group they stand about
ten feet behind me in this girl
this girl's back is to them and they
proceeded to start saying hey George hey
George and then doing this symbol if you
can describe it okay right now he does a
little like a little okay sign in the
hole he kicks his other finger and
sticks his finger in the okay sign you
say are you saying that that's sexual
penetration yes that's what they were
trying to help oh that's the semaphore
they were doing when I was trying to
chat with this girl instead of joining
them I thought like I come from I grew
up in the circus it's a it's a tiger
running through a circle of flames yeah
I grew up in the circus but
so I keep on trying to like make sure
like the conversation keeps going with
this girl so she doesn't turn around and
see them like every time they like
George hopper second am i interrupting
you
I saw what season two kalila yes baby
you look at me right now yeah baby you
have to come on now put Steve look at me
right baby baby I'm on the [ __ ]
precipice okay of snapping all right go
ahead I know that's what I'm saying so
about to happen and I'm about to [ __ ] it
I'll go ahead so uh I thought I avoided
her seeing anything of my good friends
uh just doing that yeah being very
childish and doing it took joke sane
yeah big very yeah very insensitive to
me like we were getting along great
listen I don't know I might have had a
great time with this girl who knows they
were being obnoxious exactly yeah
so uh we all go to another bar she said
she's had enough to drink
and so I walk into her car about a week
later I text her no response a couple
weeks after that I call her no response
hmm I think maybe she had seen my
friends you know being good friends and
uh actually very rude friends basically
cock-blocking me a week a couple months
later I like finally I finally email her
no response I'm like okay this is not
going anywhere my good friend so as I
like to say Bobby yeah yeah yeah you two
are a good friend
oh you guys might rage go ahead guys
calm down
last week you may have blown up my
personal life and there is a subset yeah
yeah there's a section of the female
populace who might not like their uh
their personal life to be on on blast
and in order to have a relationship with
me
they might uh think Oh Bobby's gonna put
me on blast there are many people that
may may not like this and so you're so
you're saying George let me get this
straight
the gist of your story is
you thought bobby was a good friend when
he just really comes no he's he's just
like all rather than Fri so right now
look at me right now you're like all my
other good friend your what happened we
blew it up he ruined it for you the girl
no longer wants to speak with you I mean
not doesn't want to be in a room she
just wants to be friends now I'm just
saying there's there's people out there
that in may there might be a large group
of people who know starch this is your
problem when you try to confront
somebody about things be explicit what
did Bobby do wrong he did he [ __ ] it up
for you you blew up my [ __ ] joint
dawg this is right here your peace
what's your yeah there's no peace oh
okay
number one and I I'm stating number one
right now I'm stating the facts okay
okay
facts okay last week let me ask you a
question you [ __ ] got you my friend
all right no I was gonna [ __ ] put you
on blast last week before the podcast
yeah did you look at me right now did
you know that I was gonna talk about it
great attorney before the [ __ ]
podcast no but you know what the content
of what I'm about to say right but you
already knew what I was gonna do so let
me tell you guys something right now
last week I said that you know he's been
hanging out with coladas from Jessica
who is in Korean Aggie seen a monster
yeah it's not mean that's fine alright
if you look at a [ __ ] toad and you
don't call it a toad and he says I'm a
I'm a Wolverine you're toad yeah you're
not a Wolverine exactly the only one who
ever says that he pulled some major
major great dick which is you know there
are mysteries of life based on mysteries
of life the Loch Ness monster Loch Ness
monster what and whatnot Thank You
Gilbert for [ __ ] backing me up
alright but there are mysteries of life
and I listen to me right now okay you
already knew I was gonna say okay and
number two
you are not and this is what I'm trying
to teach you a friend
right right now I'm being a I'm a
prophet I'm your [ __ ] prophet okay
and don't roll your eyes [ __ ] don't be
sorry I want to say this you're not a
closer
and I've been watching you for years
you're not a closer
you can open the game but you don't know
how to close and I'm teaching you how to
close I want to tell you a story my
friend may I tell you a story a long
time ago I owned a skate store did you
know that yeah he was called juvie it
was in Silver Lake
all right I was part owner with my
friend Callisto one day I'm working in
the skate store and this girl walks in
beautiful girl skate girl this right
here I like this girl right here right
so I took her to dinner got her number
and whatnot okay and then like a week
later I call Fox night I don't know I
don't feel it
so I'm gonna I got to take it to the
next level so I took her to Vegas I took
her to Vegas with a bunch of friends of
mine okay and this is when I was on
drugs so this is over 14 years ago and I
got I drank I took some ecstasy I know
where she was and it opened up a closet
of my hotel room and my friend
it's [ __ ] her in the closet I shut
the closet and I went back to sleep
I think I didn't yell at my [ __ ]
friend you know why cuz I didn't claim
that [ __ ] yet I didn't close the deal
and when the deal is not closed it's not
my product okay I'm using it in in a
business analogy I'm not saying that
women are property I'm saying they're
all human being real flesh and bone we
have spirits and souls okay that's what
I'm saying all right well what I'm
saying is is that you right you take too
long you don't close the deal and that
should have been yours you don't ask a
girl he's so I met this other girl I was
wondering
um where this is going she's gonna be
like no we're dog I think you're wrong I
know no you're not wrong I'm not wrong
tell her tell him how I closed your deal
I was like hey there's no way there's no
reason on God's green earth that I
should be dating her
there's no it doesn't make sense in life
it doesn't make sense to the universe or
God or anything else but I did tell him
I said hey I don't think I'm ready to be
in a relationship and I'm actually
leaving for London in two weeks he was
like nah [ __ ]
my girl no you're my girlfriend you
ain't going nowhere and I was like wait
what yeah he was like yeah you're my
girlfriend and if she would have gone
[Music]
you lost and I just I just acquiesced I
said oh I am because yeah I've been
telling people for a long time you're my
girlfriend so you're my girl yeah I mean
she probably made a bad mistake this
could have been not the best life for
her but she's in okay so look at me
right now my friend I'm gonna go [ __ ]
look at his Reggie's pretty red ring I
know he's Pinker than pay he's bigger
than pink yeah which is right what you
lose is red okay I really like you man I
do we talk about you all the time we go
to high aren't we lucky to have George
on our team and um you should come to my
shows you you deal with all the like the
stickers mailing them out and I don't
even know what's going on you do
everything that's why this podcast I'm
splitting it four ways down the middle
you know I know that I'm the bigger star
here and don't don't don't argue against
that know his heart right I'm the
biggest star I love it listen look at me
right now in fact I want everyone to say
it you're the biggest star everyone
right on the couch all together yeah
Bobby Lee you're the biggest star
I didn't hear George George you see it
on your
because I'm here you thank you and don't
ever drop Cassim cheese [ __ ] [ __ ] a
room again or any youtube star I respect
them okay I'm there are my peers but
don't threaten me with that stuff okay
go ahead I'm not done yet but I just
want to say that I'm I'm sorry
no you're sorry no I'm sorry here's what
I'm sorry about I'm sorry that you
reacted the way you did okay and I'm
sorry that you didn't close the deal and
I'm sorry that right now you're gonna
grow and you're gonna be a [ __ ] man
one day but you're not a closer
and I want you to learn to be a closing
that's it me and that's the end of the
story you have anything else to say
George I have something to say defend
George I did you say to friend I think
you don't want to hear this [ __ ] faces
think one George is a man he is a man
very much - wait wait - all right how
did we know he's not doing the long con
[ __ ] a long con though you don't get
your dick wet with whatever we don't
know if he could probably get the dick
sucked all the time we don't know that
what if he's trying to like I want the
girlfriend I know then if that's the I
usually can tell if a guy's pulling a
long con I've seen pictures of his
you've seen pictures of long has cons
long cons generally do not work it's
it's not that's its science
I would actually grade it was it doesn't
work knows what do you mean yeah well I
know what a long I used to do long high
used to own funds yeah long con is when
you meet a girl you're attracted to her
you know you you go you don't want I
just want to hang out with this girl
and I'm gonna take my time with it you
know but you know what a lot of that is
is fear it's fear of you not making a
move and to get rejected but the thing
is is that the problem with the long con
is long cons always turn into friendzone
oh oh almost always turns into
friendzone and they when she and when
you're in the friend zone
it's almost impossible to get out
because once somebody's in the
friendzone because I've been friend
zones and I've also seen other people in
friend zones you have to then to save it
you have to do the reverse cut them off
completely
mmm sorry guys can you grab me a tissue
my left nostrils keep sneaking and I
keep walking I think I have a deviated
septum
only my left nostril keeps leaking I
have um I now want to say something
about Jorge like oh it's black tissue
you're gonna want to see that white snot
all over that yeah sorry I'm totally
Donald Trump me with my sniffing nice I
I want to say that it's refreshing to
see a guy like George who's not
pretentious who's not trying to pull any
games who's actually coming off and
actually courting somebody in a very
true
not pushy not aggressive not angry when
she says no and I can really really
appreciate how he's gone about this my
only constructive criticism about the
whole thing is I know my best friend and
my best friend is a tough nut to crack
and she's very feisty so you almost have
to manhandle her in a way where she's
like where you're like look at me look
at me yeah not in an aggressive way but
in an assertive way in a calm assertion
because because she's an animal I'm an
animal herd I respond
George her and I respond to very similar
ways of of of being approached and it's
not it's not in any way like aggressive
it's just really [ __ ] assertive where
it's like I know my place in your life
and you ought to see it too type thing
that's my only advice my only tip going
forward I think I would be happy I said
this before for someone for her to date
someone like you but we gotta feel it in
our groin we got to feel that that fuel
just wanting a [ __ ] our loins to want
to jump out at you yeah and you don't do
that without by by by being Bobby just
spit on his hand and touch
what does this say what does it say what
is the sticker say I declare war on your
[ __ ] nuff said war that's such a good
thing so worth and let me see something
right now you have anything else to say
to me that's all you're saying long-form
is that all you have on defense well his
I mean I was in the situation on this
podcast early on get your spot blown up
it's hard to do when your spots blown up
speaking of which let's blow Gilbert's
pot up New York I know I'm not done with
this yet but I will get into that okay
okay
you also had another situation where
some girl came along I want a show like
you know I mean a woman that one other
girl I didn't like her I don't like her
you know what I'm not gonna blow her
spot up but what I'm saying is is that I
feel like he is it's a thing with him
yes to be in the friend zones and not
closing a deal and having drinks no you
have to grab them on the wrist not not
not literally okay right here
metaphorically and you got to pull it
back you know American Indian you're
scalping somebody take it or leave it
because I'm gonna take it everyone
listen hey so that's your lesson to
learn and if I ever see you in this
situation again I am gonna blow you back
up again I want to take this moment also
to say on the ref for the record if you
ever date that girl that you brought
around me that ended up hitting on
Gilbert which this relationship is over
no I I dislike her deeply I just like
her so deeply for you she is not long
conning anyone she is a con and I
guarantee you that woman to woman I felt
her vibe
ever if you ever bring cons into my
[ __ ] lotto our family you have
another thing coming
she was I don't know why you're angry
mommy all right
she was hyping him up having [ __ ] sex
seeing all this stuff and then she came
to stay in George's place and then
[ __ ] hit on Gilbert I don't know how
to get her spot up because I just don't
like her I don't like her for you for
you for you her for us yeah I mean
obviously I can't tell you what to do
but like God don't ever bring that [ __ ]
around me again
so those torts Kimble long con work so
to wrap it up you're forgiven to wrap it
up don't worry I don't wrap it up but I
also want you to say I'm sorry I let me
just here I'm sorry
[Music]